.
Eine innere Stimme sagte mir:
"Jetzt gehst du einfach da hin!"
Mit einer völlig fremden Person.
Es gab keine andere Lösung,
um zusammen zu sein,
als einander das Jawort zu geben.
"Okay." Am nächsten Tag gingen
wir aufs Standesamt und heirateten.
* Romantischer Popsong:
"Take my hand" von Adrian Stern *
# Take my hand. Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me.
# Take my hand.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Hin und weg war sie.
Was Claudia aus Zürich an Yakhouba
aus Paris so faszinierend fand,
dass sie vor über zehn Jahren
definitiv nach Amerika zog,
möchte ich herausfinden.
Seither sind noch zwei Mädchen
dazugekommen: Ariana und Alessia.
You pull it out?
- No, my turn!
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
- I win again, so I'm first.
Der ehemalige Profibasketballer
schmeisst inzwischen
einen grossen Teil des Haushalts.
No, you do it wrong!
- Okay, do it again!
Kann er kochen?
- Ja, wirklich.
Er kann kochen.
Aber von dir gelernt?
- Ja, von mir gelernt.
Er kann nur Pizza,
Spaghetti und Risotto.
Including the pizza dough.
- Yeah, pizza dough.
Wie ist das?
Vorher hast du alles geschmissen.
Viele haben Mühe,
den Haushalt abzugeben.
War das bei dir nie ein Thema?
Ich finde es super.
Ich komme jeweils gar nicht heim.
Nur wegen der Kinder!
I don't want it.
- ... prepare.
Es ist gut,
er macht's gut mit den Kindern.
Manchmal gibt es
Meinungsverschiedenheiten,
was sie dürfen und was nicht.
- Du bist strenger? - Ja.
Streng ist Profiköchen Claudia
auch mit ihrem Ehemann Khoub.
Aber der nimmt's locker.
Yes, good job.
Oh, yeah!
- I'm a natural.
Rise and shine.
"Rise and shine"
hat auch gut zu Claudia gepasst.
Schon mit 18 ging sie
als Zirkusartistin in die USA,
performte später als Profitänzerin
für Stars wie Jay-Z oder Destiny's
Child und sang selber in Musikvideos.
# I want it, baby. Yeah yeah yeah.
Yakhouba Diawara
spielte auf seinem Karrierehöhepunkt
bei den Miami Heats in der NBA.
Der Sohn senegalesischer Einwanderer
wuchs in den Pariser Banlieus
in einfachsten Verhältnissen auf.
Basketball
hat mich eigentlich gerettet.
Wenn ich nicht Sport getrieben
hätte, wäre ich wohl noch dort.
Meine Mutter hat mir beigebracht,
zu tun, was man tun möchte.
Sie war eine Krampferin.
Sie und mein Vater standen immer um
5 Uhr auf, um nach Paris zu fahren,
um dort Läden zu putzen.
Mein Vater arbeitete
als Strassenreiniger.
Es war immer mein Traum,
mit dem Sport
so viel Geld zu verdienen,
dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten müssen.
Das habe ich gemacht.
Khoub und Claudia
gingen beide sehr jung
aus Europa allein nach Amerika,
um grosse Träume zu verwirklichen.
Das habe sie von Anfang an
miteinander verbunden.
Du hast getanzt, in Videos,
hast dir eine Karriere aufgebaut.
Dann hast du ihn kennengelernt
und gemerkt,
dass du alles aufgeben musst, wenn
du mit ihm zusammen sein willst.
Am Anfang versuchte ich,
weiter zu machen, was ich machte:
tanzen, singen, turnen, Zirkus.
Aber es ging nicht.
Wir sahen uns nicht.
Eine Spielerfrau
muss immer bei ihrem Mann sein,
denn es gibt so viel zu tun -
was ich nicht wusste.
Man hat so viele Verpflichtungen.
was denn?
Die Sporttasche hinter ihm hertragen?
Man muss immer schauen,
dass sie alles haben,
dass das Essen da ist,
wenn sie essen müssen,
dass sie ausruhen können,
keine Anrufe kommen, wenn sie ...
Hat man dafür keine Manager oder so?
Muss das wirklich ...
Doch, aber es wird halt
immer alles gemacht für sie.
Sie sind es gewohnt, dass sich
alle auf alle Seiten biegen.
Die Frauen ... Ich glaube, das ist,
um sie auch etwas zu beschäftigen.
Wir hatten oft irgendeinen Luncheon,
man muss da hin und sich anhören,
was sie alles sagen,
dann gibt es Silence Auctions,
wo man Täschchen oder so
billiger kaufen kann,
oder irgendeinen Retreat,
wo die Frauen hin müssen,
oder NBA Care,
da muss man Dinge ins Homeless
oder Women's Shelter bringen.
Man muss zu all den Spielerfrauen-
Events und immer gut aussehen.
Man muss eigentlich
die Identität verlieren.
Es heisst immer: "Ah,
das ist die Frau von Blablabla."
Ich so:
"Hello, I got a career, too!"
Und doch hast du alles aufgegeben.
Warum?
Natürlich für ihn, für uns,
für unsere Zukunft
und was wir für unsere Familie
erreichen wollten.
Ich merkte:
Ich muss da sein.
So viele Frauen wollten
mit meinem Mann zusammen sein.
Wenn ich nicht da bin
oder eine Minute nicht aufpasse,
kommen sie aus allen Löchern.
Wir nennen sie mushrooms.
Sie kommen
so schnell zum Boden raus.
Ich musste da sein, um aufzupassen.
Hast du gemerkt, dass so viele Frauen
um dich geworben haben?
Ja, das habe ich
schon im College gemerkt.
Da kommen alle zu den Spielen.
Man ist schon ein bisschen ein Star.
Als Profi hat sich das
verzehn- oder verzwanzigfacht.
By ten? By a thousand!
Die Leute sehen dich im Fernsehen,
wissen, dass du viel Geld verdienst
und ein gutes Leben führst.
Daran wollen sie
natürlich teilhaben.
Ariana und Alessia
sind in Amerika geboren
und kennen die Schweiz nur
von Besuchen bei den Grosseltern.
Sie reden mit ihren Eltern Englisch.
Schweizerdeutsch können sie abgesehen
von wenigen Wörtern nicht.
Ausser eben: Bratwurst.
I like Switzerland,
because they have Bratwurst.
Yeah. St. Galler Bratwurst.
Bratwurst, ihr erstes
Schweizerdeutsches Wort.
As soon as we get
out of the airport.
They have a stand outside.
Der Sternen am Flughafen, weisst du.
- Der Sternen Grill, ja.
Da gehen wir immer als erstes hin.
Wir haben Kinder, Familie,
müssen sicherstellen,
dass alle zufrieden sind.
Wir haben eine Vorstellung,
wie wir es machen.
Aber vielleicht
landen wir in einer Sackgasse.
Und natürlich gab es auch Zweifel
daran, ob das alles klappen wird.
Kannst du rückwärts gehen,
oder soll ich? - Es geht.
Buschi, geh weg!
1'500 km trennen Florence von Niklas,
aber beide arbeiten
an ihrem gemeinsamen Projekt:
ein Haus mitten im schwedischen Wald.
Ein gemeinsames Zuhause für sie
und mind. acht Hunde.
Tipptopp.
Der sollte nachher in Schweden
bei uns im Schlafzimmer
seinen Platz finden.
Ich hänge ein wenig an diesem Stück.
Ich habe ihn von meiner Mutter
zum 20. Geburtstag bekommen.
Er ist mittlerweile
nicht mehr so schön.
Die Kinder haben da
mal Buchstaben eingeritzt.
Ich möchte ihn nun anthrazit
und ockerfarben streichen.
Damit er dort
schön ins Schlafzimmer passt.
In einem guten Jahr
möchte Florence umziehen.
Weg aus Derendingen,
weg aus der Schweiz,
weg von Töchtern und Familie.
Es ist wohl der letzte Frühling
in diesem Haus,
das letzte Mal, dass ich sehe,
wie die Rebe da drüben grün wird.
Jetzt ist der Moment,
wo ich sagen kann:
Es ist der letzte Frühling, der
letzte Sommer, der letzte Herbst.
Vorher kam immer jeweils noch einer.
Es wird mir daher
schon immer mehr bewusst.
Hi, Florence!
- Hi, hi!
Your delivery. Geht's gut?
- Ja, thank you. You?
Perfekt, merci.
Let me take this. Oh, perfect.
Your Easter bunny.
- Oh, my Easter bunny. Amazing.
I was looking at it so many times.
Is that the right one?
- Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Ah, okay.
So that is the old ochre.
And graphite.
Das Gute ist:
Du kannst einfach drübermalen.
Du musst es nicht abschleifen.
Okay. That was the question.
No sanding.
Nothing. You just need to ...
we say: spinnwebenfrei, staubfrei.
Nicht zu viel Farbe auf den Pinsel.
Perfekt.
Florence
ist bestens eingebettet hier.
Sie hat ein gutes soziales Netz.
Das gibt sie alles auf
für ihren schwedischen Mann.
Eine grosse Verantwortung für Niklas.
Er ist sich dessen sehr bewusst.
Darum ist es ihm auch wichtig,
dass ich mich dort wohlfühle.
Er lässt mir da ziemlich freie Hand.
Wenn ich sage, ich hätte gerne
noch das oder das,
habe ich am nächsten Tag quasi
schon einen Plan in den Händen,
und er sagt: "Schau,
wir könnten das so oder so machen."
Ja, da kann ich mich nicht beklagen.
Das macht mir manchmal
fast ein bisschen Angst.
Nein, wirklich.
Nur beim Hundethema kämpfen wir
noch etwas um die Anzahl.
Noya ist 17 Jahre alt.
Ihre ältere Schwester Laura
ist schon ausgezogen.
Für Noya wird auch vieles anders,
wenn ihre Mutter nach Schweden geht.
Man merkt schon:
Langsam geht es dem Ende zu.
Sie geht bald. Ich habe natürlich
immer bei meiner Mutter gewohnt.
Wir reden oft darüber, wie es
nachher weitergeht und wie es wird.
Die Vorstellung,
wie es ist, wenn sie dann weg ist.
Wir reden schon oft darüber. Es
ist natürlich ein präsentes Thema.
Noya hat eine Angststörung
und kann darum kaum reisen.
Das macht den Abschied von der Mutter
noch viel schwieriger.
Es ist eben ein grosses Thema.
Mami sagt immer,
ich soll unbedingt mal mitgehen.
Und ich immer so: "Hm ..."
Wegen dieses Problems eben.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Ziel
von mir, dass ich sie besuchen will.
Das möchte ich schon irgendwie
auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ein Jahr bleibt den beiden noch.
Für ihn war von Anfang an klar,
dass er für eine Weile
in die Schweiz kommen möchte.
Daher hat sich die Frage nicht gross
gestellt, wo wir zuerst leben.
Es war klar,
dass das die Schweiz sein würde.
Dass wir aber Australien auch mal
ausprobieren wollten, war klar.
Das wussten wir.
Wir wussten aber nicht wann,
und wie lange wir
in der Schweiz sein würden.
Das war alles noch etwas offen.
* Heitere, erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Vor 48 Std. flogen Martina und Cahil
total überstürzt in Zürich ab.
Wegen der Corona-Krise
und der Grenzschliessung
sind sie viel früher aus der Schweiz
weg als ursprünglich geplant.
Kein Moment zu früh, wie sich zeigt.
Machst du dir Sorgen
wegen des Virus?
Not really.
Das Einzige,
worüber ich mir Sorgen mache,
ist, dass ich das Virus
in deine Familie bringen könnte.
Aber ich habe kein einziges Symptom
und fühle mich gut.
I'm not worried.
* Sanfte, lebhafte Klaviermusik *
Hier an der australischen Westküste
ist Cahil aufgewachsen.
Bis er vor zwei Jahren
zu Martina nach Buochs zog,
hatte er Australien
noch nie verlassen.
Ah, finally.
Noch eine Stunde,
dann sind wir in Noosa.
Let's do it!
(Schweizerdeutsch)
Hey, das ist ja auch krass:
Deine Mutter hat dir geschrieben,
ab heute um 21 Uhr kämen wir
nicht mehr nach Australien.
Also nur noch Australier.
(Deutsch)
Ja. Und wir sind nur 3 Std. vorher.
Ja, oh mein Gott.
3 Std. später und wir wären
nicht mehr reingekommen.
Puh!
- Wirklich krass.
Wegen 3 Std.
haben wir es noch geschafft.
Ich bin so froh, wirklich.
(Englisch) Meine Mutter
wird sich extrem freuen.
Sie erwarten uns überhaupt nicht.
No, they got no idea.
- Not one bit.
V.a. jetzt mit dem Coronavirus.
Wir dachten ja auch,
wir könnten nicht fliegen.
Ich bin so froh,
dass wir jetzt hier sind.
Ja, die haben keine Ahnung.
Well, this is where it all begins.
- Yeah.
Ich zittere. Ich bin so nervös.
Die zwei haben niemandem gesagt,
dass sie heute ankommen.
Es soll eine Überraschung für
Cahils Eltern und Schwester werden.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Lachen *
* Bellen *
Hey! How are you?
Good.
Überraschung!
How did you do that?
Oh, my goodness!
Hätte ich das gewusst, hätte ich
abgewaschen und mich gekämmt.
We wanted to surprise you guys.
Vater zieht gerade seine Uniform an
und macht sich auf zur Arbeit.
But he's here.
He was just sitting on the deck.
But he needs to leave for work now?
He does.
- Oh, no.
Hey!
How are you doing?
Welche Überraschung!
You snuck up on us!
- Yes.
You guys were worried we wouldn't
make it. We were worried, too!
Die letzten 48 Std.
waren so aufregend.
They said 9 o'clock or something.
Yes. Joanna said that.
But we were happy,
because it said Australian citizens
and direct family.
So. No foreigners. So what.
You're ...
(Mit hoher Stimme) Hey, good boy!
How are you? How are you?
Hey, Genie. Oh!
Hey, Gina. Is your daddy home?
Das ist die beste Überraschung
in meinem ganzen Leben.
We're really happy.
See you tomorrow.
Love you, Marty.
So glad we could make that happen.
Ich danke dir ganz fest,
dass du so gut
auf meinen Jungen aufgepasst hast.
Yeah, that's true.
He's a sloppy Aussie and
you're a refined little Swiss girl.
Alright, party's over.
Out of the pool!
See you tomorrow.
That was a short hug, but anyway.
Ein Happyend nach einer langen
und ungewissen Reise.
Und der Start des gemeinsamen Lebens
in Australien in Cahils Heimat.
* Er seufzt. *
Meine Heimat ist immer
auch die Schweiz.
Sie würde ich
als meine Heimat bezeichnen.
Aber wir leben hier,
weil es besser ist für uns.
Für Koubs Job, für meinen Job,
und auch für die Kinder.
Obwohl ich gerne zu Hause
in der Schweiz sein würde.
Ich nenne es
immer noch mein Zuhause.
Da hätten sie Omi, Opi und meine
Schwester. Das wäre auch schön.
Aber wir könnten in der Schweiz
nicht das machen,
was wir hier machen.
* Tragende Gitarrenklänge *
Heute begleite ich Claudia
zur Arbeit.
Sie ist Private Chef,
also Privatköchin.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
was mich erwartet.
* Tragende Gitarrenklänge *
Wohin gehen wir jetzt?
Wir gehen zu meinem Kunden.
Er ist gerade im Training.
Wir kochen für ihn,
lassen das Essen für ihn dort,
und wenn er nach Hause kommt,
wärmt er es für sich auf.
Ja.
- M-hm.
Und er ist ... Was macht er?
Er ist professioneller
Footballspieler.
Also ein richtiger rich guy?
Ja, einfach einer dieser Spieler.
Auch ein Athlet, wie Khoub.
Du machst das v.a. für Profisportler?
Eigentlich nur Profisportler
oder andere high end clients.
Wir - ich habe mehrere Chefs,
also Köche, die unter mir arbeiten.
Sie sind bei mir angestellt
und ich vermittle sie,
denn ich kann nicht alle Kunden
selber annehmen.
In Florida und Atlanta.
Ein paar Kunden
wollen explizit mich,
und bei ihnen zu Hause koche ich,
so oft ich kann.
Jetzt kommen dann
die schöneren Häuser.
Das ist das Villenviertel?
Das ist der hintere Teil
von Roswell,
wo sehr viele Athleten wohnen.
Da kommt ein grosses, schau!
- Oh, ja.
Das ist kein Parlamentsgebäude, gell.
* Claudia lacht. *
Das ist ein Privathaus.
- Das kannst du kaufen, Mona.
Das hier ist es?
- Das hier, ja.
Das hier? Oh.
Dass in Amerika alles etwas grösser
ist, weiss man ja eigentlich.
Aber ein Basketballfeld auf dem
Vorplatz hat auch hier nicht jeder.
Hast du einen Schlüssel oder wie?
- Ich habe einen Geheimcode.
* Mona lacht. *
Das sind alles seine?
Das sind alles seine. Er hat noch
mehr, aber die sind nicht hier.
* Dynamische, drollige Musik *
Ich habe fast ein wenig Angst,
jemand schiesst gleich auf uns.
Nein, er weiss, dass wir hier sind.
Das ist die Küche.
Ich mache Licht.
Hier drin ... Ja.
Ein begehbarer Esswarenschrank!
Ja. Wir stellen
immer alles schön aus.
Hier sind all meine Messer.
Hier ist noch mehr ... ähm, Gewürz.
Alle Pastasorten, die ich habe.
Ich dachte immer,
das höchste der Gefühle
sei ein begehbarer Schuh-
oder Kleiderschrank für Frauen.
Aber dass es begehbare
Vorratsschränke gibt ...
Wir stellen eben
immer gern alles aus,
und er mag das auch.
Ich finde es cool,
wenn wir immer sehen, was wir haben.
Irgendjemand hat mein Gewürz
durcheinandergebracht.
Aber sonst ...
Aber das ist nicht nur so
ausgestellt, er lebt hier so?
Ja, er kann eigentlich auch kochen,
will einfach nicht.
Und er mag es,
ab und zu eine Frau hier zu haben,
weil er meist allein
in diesem riesigen Haus ist.
Okay. Dann seid ihr
fast ein wenig befreundet?
Ja, schon. Aber ich arbeite für ihn.
Man muss immer aufpassen, man kann
nicht zu nah befreundet sein.
Es kann nicht wirklich
eine Freundschaft entstehen.
Oder sollte nicht.
Klar kann es passieren.
Aber es ist besser,
es professionell zu behalten.
Sonst wird es schwierig
mit dem Arbeiten und der Bezahlung.
Man muss eine Balance finden.
Wie macht man das?
- Klare Grenzen setzen.
Von dir aus auch?
- Ja.
Man kann schon mal zu einem Spiel
gehen oder mal zusammen ausgehen,
aber nicht regelmässig.
Man muss immer daran denken -
das ist wichtig -
dass man für ihn arbeitet
und nicht Teil der Entourage
oder der Familie ist.
Ich muss ein Messer rausnehmen.
Wie alt ist er?
- Er ist 30.
Das ist eigentlich schon ...
Mitte Karriere. Oder fast Ende.
Nein, Anfangs ... - Aha.
- Irgendwie schon noch.
Während Claudia
das Essen bereitmacht,
kümmert sich Khoub
zu Hause um die Kinder.
Als wandelnder Kletterbaum.
Für etwas hat man schliesslich
einen 2 m grossen Papi.
Jackfruit.
Wie hat er sich
in diese Rolle hineingefunden?
Ähm, er ist eigentlich
reingerutscht, also musste einfach.
Off season hatte er ja jeweils ...
... nichts, kein Job, also musste
auf den neuen Vertrag warten.
Ich begann zu arbeiten
und sagte dann:
"Ich arbeite jetzt,
du musst jetzt zu Hause bleiben."
"Du kannst nicht irgendwo hingehen."
Er musste ein paar Verträge
deswegen auch absagen.
Okay.
Habt ihr manchmal
auch Diskussionen deswegen?
Nein. Er findet es toll, er ist
sehr stolz. Das ist mega herzig.
Stolz auf dich?
- Stolz auf mich. Ja. Das ist cool.
Hättest du gedacht,
dass er das so packt?
Du hast ihn in einem
ganz anderen Setting kennengelernt.
Alles drehte sich immer um ihn.
Er findet es cool.
Wir er sagte:
Früher hat er uns immer Tickets
von Kollegen gegeben.
Jetzt bekomme ich ständig Tickets
für Games oder Partys.
Nicht mehr er.
Und er hat kein Problem damit,
dass du bread winner bist
und das Geld nach Hause bringst?
- Nein. Er gibt's gern aus.
Ach ja? Wofür?
- Für Kinderspielsachen.
Immer, wenn ich heimkomme,
ist da ein neuer Spielwarenladen.
Dann gibt es grosse Diskussionen.
Weil du findest ...
Ich verdiene schon gut, aber nicht
so gut wie er, als er spielte.
Ich verdiene genug zum Leben.
Du kochst immer
hier in dieser Küche?
Nein, es gibt drei Küchen.
Ich koche meistens hier.
Samstag und Sonntag koche ich oben,
bei seinem Zimmer
ist eine sehr schöne Küche.
Und wenn es viele Leute hat,
koche ich unten.
Wir können es uns anschauen.
Wir dürfen uns hier bewegen?
Eben. Manchmal koche ich
in der Küche hier unten.
Hier sind ein paar seiner Shirts.
Mit denen er gespielt hat.
Okay. Das ist seine Spielerhöhle.
Hier kannst du Golf spielen.
Sicher nicht.
Da hinten kochen wir manchmal.
Das ist ja noch mal eine riesige ...
Wenn wir Partys oder so haben, koche
ich hier oder wärme das Zeug auf.
Sie sind dann
meistens im Movie Theater.
Das ist da drüben.
- Das ist sein Kino.
Sein privates Kino.
Ich krieg mich nicht mehr ein.
Und dann? Kommen Freunde her
und essen Pommes Chips?
Da hinten ist eine Snack Bar.
Wir füllen die Bonbons und so auf,
machen frisches Popcorn.
Und was ist das für ein Ball?
So cool.
Ein wenig ...
Ich werde auch bald 50,
da hat man das Gefühl:
Ich mache das jetzt oder nie!
Es ist die Zeit gekommen,
das Leben etwas zu geniessen.
Ich hatte Kinder,
habe viel gearbeitet,
es war immer alles
ein wenig darauf ausgerichtet.
Jetzt ist ein wenig Zeit,
sich zurückzulehnen,
mit der Natur zu leben,
in diesem Wald draussen zu sein,
auch mal die Einsamkeit
und sich selber etwas zu spüren.
Darauf freue ich mich unheimlich.
Noch ist es nicht so weit.
Der Frühling 2020 hat das Leben
auf der ganzen Welt
auf den Kopf gestellt.
Auch jenes von Florence und Niklas.
Wegen der Coronakrise
sind die regelmässigen Besuche
vorläufig nicht mehr möglich.
Ja, das stellt uns jetzt
natürlich auf eine harte Probe.
Wir haben uns zuletzt
vor fünf Wochen gesehen.
Im Moment wissen wir nicht,
wann das nächste Mal sein wird.
Das steht jetzt natürlich
einfach in den Sternen.
Wir können nichts planen, nichts ...
Es ist im Moment
relativ schwierig für uns beide.
Schwedens Grenzen sind ja noch offen
aber die der Schweiz nicht mehr.
Er kann nicht einreisen,
ich habe das abgeklärt.
Und ich kann momentan
nicht nach Schweden reisen.
Direkte Flüge
gibt es schon gar nicht mehr,
ich könnte nur zuerst über Amsterdam
und dann über Berlin.
Die ganze Reise würde 23 Std. dauern
und Tausende Franken kosten.
Da ist im Moment gar nichts möglich,
auch mit dem Auto nicht,
weil Deutschlands Grenzen
ja auch geschlossen sind.
Da ist im Moment gar nichts möglich.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Freizeichen *
Hi.
- Hallo!
Wie geht's dir?
Mir geht's gut. Und dir?
Hast du Stress?
Ja.
- Okay.
Wir haben
mit Corona-Jobs angefangen.
What are Corona-Jobs?
Wir montieren Plexiglas
an Rezeptionen und Kassen.
Stuff like this.
War etwas mit dem Haus heute?
Nein. Heute war niemand dort.
Wie geht's dir im Quarantäneland?
Immer noch gleich.
Still the same.
Ich lasse dich jetzt
zu deinen Corona-Jobs.
Ja. Wir haben
immer noch drei Orte vor uns.
Bist du okay?
Ja. Klar.
Good.
Okay. Bye, bye!
* Sanfte Musik *
Komm her, Max!
Komm her!
* Sie schnalzt. *
Hopp!
Eine Fernbeziehung als Ehepaar
zu führen ist per se schon schwierig.
Aber wenn ein Virus
noch die Grenzen dichtmacht,
möchte man manchmal verzweifeln.
Wann sich Florence und Niklas
wieder sehen können,
steht in den Sternen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wir haben beide die Einstellung:
Wir leben jetzt.
Viele planen so weit voraus,
sparen und sparen,
haben Hunderttausende Franken
auf dem Konto.
Wir finden:
Wir möchten das jetzt nutzen.
Wir wissen nicht, was morgen ist,
was in zwei Jahren ist.
Wir möchten beide mehr in die Natur,
mehr das machen, was wir lieben.
Mehr unsere Leidenschaften leben
als jeden Tag 8 1/2 Std. im Büro
zu sein, von Montag bis Freitag.
* Entspannt-drollige Musik *
Im Jetzt leben,
machen, worauf man Lust hat:
Das klingt nach einer Einladung
nach Noosa im Westen Australiens.
Hier in Cahils Elternhaus
müssen Martina und ihr Mann
nach der überstürzten Abreise
aus der Schweiz
zwei Wochen in Quarantäne verbringen.
Babe?
Schatz?
- Ja.
Your tea.
Thank you.
* Bellen *
Bernie! No!
Should we sit outside?
It's so beautiful.
So strahlend
der australische Sommer wirkt,
Martina hat viel aufgegeben
in der Schweiz.
Die Arbeit als Leiterin einer
Kinderkrippe, ihre Freunde.
Und der Abschied von den Eltern
und der Zwillingsschwester
sitzt auch noch in den Knochen.
Hm? Isn't it beautiful?
Ich freue mich trotzdem mega.
Es ist etwas,
das wir unbedingt wollten.
Wir wollten
nach Australien zurückkommen.
Auch ich. Ich habe
Cahils Familie auch vermisst.
Na ja, jetzt ist es
etwas anders als geplant.
Es ist okay für uns.
Jetzt sind wir mal hier.
Unten ist ein Pool, wir können
also trotzdem sonnenbaden.
Vielleicht ist es auch gut,
es gibt uns die Möglichkeit,
etwas runterzufahren,
die Familie hier zu geniessen,
wenn sie nicht arbeiten,
um alles zu organisieren,
aufzuräumen,
uns Gedanken zu machen,
was wir genau wollen,
wie wir alles organisieren
und starten möchten.
vielleicht ist es nicht schlecht,
aber es ist sicher nicht so,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben.
* Lockere Musik *
Here it ist.
Etwas, worauf sich v.a. Cahil freute,
ist dieses Auto.
Are we opening
a can of worms or what?
How are you feeling?
Looks sick. Just like I remember.
- Our baby.
So cool! Aber so viel grösser,
als ich es in Erinnerung hatte.
We can't even get in without ...
Luckily we have that.
Ah!
It's not in as good a condition
as it used to be, but it's fine.
We're gonna make it.
We'll bring it back. It'll get the
job done. That's all that matters.
Von ihm selber vor Jahren umgebaut
und jetzt wieder zurückgekauft.
Mit diesem Gefährt wollen die beiden
in den nächsten Monaten
durch den ganzen Kontinent reisen.
We should probably
look at some places to ...
Ein grosser Teil
hat auch Cahil noch nie gesehen.
Sie wollen unterwegs sein,
bis ihnen das Geld ausgeht
und Martina
eine Arbeitsbewilligung bekommt.
That one looks nice.
You've got a bit of mountains,
don't you?
Nach zwei Jahren in der Schweiz
jetzt also in Australien.
Ob für ein paar Jahre oder für immer:
Cahil und Martina lassen es offen.
Okay. My god! I've got to heat up
first before I can get in there.
Mir gefällt's in Quarantäne.
It's not a bad place
to be in quarantine, is it?
Ich glaube, die nächsten zwei Wochen
werden lang.
Ist etwas heiss an der Sonne,
findest du auch?
Gehen wir rein?
Gehen wir Schwimm... wie sagt man?
...kleider? Beide?
Ja, genau, Badekleider.
Badekleider. Schwimmkleider.
- Ja.
Sie ist weder Französin
noch Muslima.
Das war vielleicht ein Problem.
Eigentlich wollte die Familie
jemanden für mich auswählen.
Deine Mama
hatte schon jemanden im Kopf.
Nicht unbedingt.
Eine Mutter halt.
Sie wollen einen immer beschützen.
Erst recht den Jüngsten, ihr Baby.
Am Ende akzeptierte sie
meine Entscheidung.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Also sagen wir, besser.
Much better than before.
Improving a lot, that's good.
To the bench.
Not so fast!
Slow down, Alessia!
Es ist Sonntag.
Familie Diawara
macht einen Ausflug ins Grüne.
* Claudia lacht. *
Grillen auf amerikanisch.
Alright.
Just open it!
- Zündest du den ganzen Sack an?
Look!
Nicht ganz wie in der Pfadi.
"Bag will burn away
and the charcoal ..."
That's what it says, right?
Whoa!
* Sie lacht. *
Behind you.
Not this one, the big one.
No. Small people take small things.
Yeah, you're right.
Wenn du im Ausland
in einer Beziehung lebst,
lässt du deine Familie immer zurück.
Bei dir schon etwa 14 Jahre.
Etwa so. Nein, fast mehr. Ich ging
mit 18 weg. Das sind 22 Jahre.
Ja, du bist mit 18 gegangen
und hast sie zurückgelassen.
Ja, ich lasse sie immer zurück.
Es war schon schwierig,
v.a., als die Kinder klein waren.
Die Kinder kurz zu Mami bringen und
selber etwas machen, lag nicht drin.
Ich muss immer auf die Schulzeit
achten, oder Khoub passt auf.
Als Khoub nicht da war,
war es schwierig.
Da war ich sozusagen
alleinerziehende Mutter.
Das hat sich definitiv geändert.
Khoub ist unterdessen
ein präsenter Vater.
Is it done yet?
Does Daddy make a good barbecue?
Yes. Better than Mommy, maybe.
Better than mommy?
- Barbecue maybe, yes.
I want Bratwurst and a ...
- Okay, relax. There's other people.
I'll have that one.
Danke vielmals.
Unterschiede gibt es viele
bei den beiden.
Herkunft, Religion, Körpergrösse.
Gemeinsamkeiten aber genauso:
Leidenschaft für das, was man macht,
die beiden Kinder
und der Glauben
an die gemeinsame Zukunft.
Wie sieht eure Zukunft aus?
Siehst du die hier in den USA
oder zurück in der Schweiz?
Zuerst sicher noch etwas hier,
und vielleicht mal in der Schweiz.
Wir wissen es noch nicht genau.
- Wovon hängt das ab?
Es kommt darauf an, ob Khoub
auch in der Schweiz arbeiten könnte.
Basketball wird auch in der Schweiz
immer grösser.
Er bekommt jetzt dann
den Schweizer Pass.
Ah!
Du bekommst den Schweizer Pass?
Wir arbeiten dran.
It takes like one year.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
die USA zu verlassen
und in der Schweiz zu leben?
Warum nicht?
Ich bin ja Europäer.
Vielleicht könnte ich
in Sachen Basketball
etwas Neues in die Schweiz bringen.
Ich könnte den Schweizer
die italienische,
die französische oder auch die
amerikanische Spielweise beibringen.
Ich hab ja überall gespielt.
Das wäre cool. Warum nicht?
Und du würdest
ein Restaurant eröffnen?
Ja, ich würde gern ein Restaurant
eröffnen in der Schweiz.
Wir überlegen zurzeit hin und her,
ob wir sollen oder nicht.
Mal abwarten, mal schauen.
Was würdest du dir für die Zukunft
eurer Familie wünschen?
Dass wir endlich mal
fix irgendwo bleiben
und nicht immer
aus dem Koffer leben müssen
mit einer Garage voller Gerümpel.
Einfach wirklich
unser Zuhause zu finden.
Mein Wunsch war es,
in der NBA zu spielen,
Kinder und eine Frau zu haben.
Nun wünsche ich mir,
alles, was ich gelernt habe,
weitergeben zu können.
Jetzt könnte ich zurückgeben,
was ich bekommen habe.
That would be nice, I think.
Ob hier oder dort:
Für Paare aus verschiedenen Ländern
ist zu Hause immer dort,
wo die Liebe sie hinführt.
Hin und weg.
* Romantische Musik *
# Take my hand!
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2020